I do think if Tony were to win this
fight there's a world where Tony gets
the Conor McGregor fight I could see
something like that happening because
Tony and Conor are supposed to fight for
a hot second Conor is going to fight
Chandler next at probably UFC 300 or
maybe a little later but there is a good
chance and as much as we love Connor
there's a good chance Conor loses that
fight so what do you do with Connor he's
not going to fight these big- time dudes
anymore he can't it's not there we need
to get him a win a Tony fergon fight
makes a lot of sense but Tony has to win
so if Tony wins what a great last fight
you finally get that elephant fight that
golden elephant that green elephant
named Conor McGregor it's a good fight
for Connor it's a good fight for Tony it
makes sense a lot of people would tune
in everyone familiar with Tony everyone
in God knows Connor he he needs to win
it'd be a good fight all the way around